when we you know decided to do a book I
we were trying to figure out like is
this gonna be a kitchen basics book is
it gonna be for like the hapless amateur
cook like we didn't really know what
direction to go and so my editor the
brilliant Brooks Martin she suggested
that I treated as an autobiography and
kind of sort of like look back at my
life through food your happy place to
actually we're gonna grab a few things
to make dinner later
we're gonna roll it right over here and
get spices so we're gonna grab one of
these you cook with tumeric I do when I
moved to West Virginia it was a little
strange for the kid with the weird name
to show up at school with cabbage rolls
and cabbage prepared in many different
ways in kielbasa when everyone else had
like the perfect crustless sandwiches
and the Oscar Mayer Lunchables like
that's all that I wanted so I kind of
weirdly grew it ashamed of of my
heritage and and my name and sort of my
cultural identity and then it wasn't
until I moved back to Montreal
I believe I referenced it in the book
there's this restaurant called stache
cafe which has been around in Montreal
for decades my father worked at this
restaurant as a waiter my sister's all
of my cousins
it's run by a family member or was
actually and it's when I started working
there and just sort of hanging out with
the grandmas in the kitchen making the
pierogies where I kind of fell in love
with you know the the cuisine of where
I'm from you're doing it today by
showing up to your mother-in-law's and
you're learning about your heritage your
ability or lack thereof to make a dish
like this does not make you any less
Mexican the show was called queer I
remember when friends were asking about
what project I was auditioning for we
weren't supposed to say what we were
auditioning for but I would always
whisper like I like I was still
uncomfortable with the word it's become
very much desensitized you know as a
result of being on it and as a result of
actually my cast mates sort of like
lifting me up and helping me be more
comfortable with myself my sexuality was
always something that was very private I
think I did certainly have a bit of
shame and being fluid when I was growing
up because I didn't know too many people
especially in pop culture or have
mentors who I could relate to or
identified to where I think the luxury
of being heterosexual is that you have a
lot of those people and in in media and
who were out there invisible and so I
kind of felt like a little bit of an
outsider so I felt like yeah I felt like
I wasn't enough of those things as well
Kenny's a man who really wants to feel
needed and feel loved and
noticed you really watching every dog
and like trying to have that eye contact
and like that interaction
yeah he's first world just hit me I
think he makes up for that by running
this social club alright because he gets
to take care of people but I think it's
taken a toll on other facets of his life
one of my mentors always told me he was
like Anthony stay in your lane and I
just try to focus on being a good person
figuring out what the next right move is
and just trying to be an example and
like visibility has been I think one of
like the main buzz words of the past two
years of just like being out there and I
I get stressed out when I think of her
like or when I get asked like what does
it feel like to be an example or to be
like a spokesperson for the lgbtqia+
community that makes me very nervous
because I'm not an expert in anything
except my opinions about food and dogs
and maybe scented candles but I just try
to I try to stay in my lane and I just
try to think I don't know when I think
of people who've inspired me in my life
I just try to think like if everything
that I do like would I be making them
proud